it changed from infinite to a finite so
infinity is real or you're saying
infinite as a standard for an extremely
large dimensionless more like extremely
large because you can't even make a
sense of a if you have a graph that's
sort of completely connected
there's no sense of dimension because
dimension requires that you take limits
of larger and larger distances in the
graph but there is no if everything's
connected everything is distance one
away so there's no way to get far away
and talk about what the large scale
limit of that is how do you get the
dimension of time in your model because
i can understand space and there's a
house door for a top a lodge but
with growing up a ball of radius
but how do you grow a ball of radius
time
it's the dimension of time defined
so
time is is
multi
you know time is going in this multi-way
graph so time
to begin with
has
in a sense it is an assumption
that is a very consciousness related
assumption that time is one dimensional
that is that there is a single thread of
experience is basically saying we're
going to conflate time until it is
one-dimensional that is our view of the
universe as soon as we put in these
foliations we are essentially assuming
that time is one dimensional it doesn't
need to be time can be
time can be off with you know there can
be many different uh paths many
different histories of the universe that
never knit together that the the the
fact that those those things are knitted
together is an assumption that's closely
related to kind of the generalized view
of consciousness